bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors est ce qu'il faut
comprendre m que le masque selon vos
clients en fait ne protégerait pas les
français face aux coronavirus alors
n'ont justement pas dire que mes clients
sont deux professionnels de santé comme
vous le savez sans doute puisque l'un
d'eux d'entre eux est médecin et notre
psychologue ce sont des praticiens
hospitaliers ou qui ne sont absolument
pas contre le mas ne sont pas des
militants qui masque au contraire ils
sont pour le masquer mais pour le masque
intelligent c'est à dire il souhaite que
les gens portent le masque
lorsque c'est nécessaire et lorsque ça
une utilité or nous estimons et mes
clients estiment que sur la voie
publique surtout à certains horaires ou
dans des zones où il n'ya pas de densité
de population il n'est pas nécessaire de
porter le masque parce qu'il n'y a aucun
risque de contamination tout simplement
parce que les règles de distanciation
physique donc les gestes barrière
peuvent être respectés sans difficulté
c'est ce que nous avons peiné devant
entre ministres hâtive de strasbourg qui
nous a donné entièrement gain de cause
et qui a suspendu avec un délai l'arrêté
de la préfète du bas-rhin et c'est ce
que notre âme en paix dès hier dimanche
après l'appel du ministre devant le
conseil d'état qui nous a également en
grande partie donné raison même s'il a
très légèrement réformé la décision de
première instance du tribunal
admistratif en enlevant le seul critère
1 les deux critères c'est à dire le
critère d'horaires donc le conseil
d'état demande simplement que la préfète
prennent un nouvel arrêté caractérisant
dans des lieux à définir et dans des
périmètres précis l'absence de
possibilité de distanciation sociale ou
la trop forte densité de population
mais c'est vrai qu'on se pose la
question face à une recrudescence des
contaminations finalement généraliser le
port du masque obligatoire c'est
peut-être la meilleure des solutions
parce que ça s'est compliqué d'en
appeler à la responsabilité de chacun
pour le respect justement des mesures
barrières alors si l'argument qui est
toujours invoquer effectivement par les
autorités publiques c'est ce qui a été
plaidé également par le préfet dans ce
dossier mais il n'y a pas eu besoin de
règles de simplicité à strasbourg nous
pouvons prendre par exemple une mesure
très simple il y à un secteur qui est
dense en population à strasbourg c'est
le centre ville qui est une ellipse
insulaire entre deux bras d'un d'une
rivière ici qui s'appelle lille
qui est très facile à délimiter et il
suffirait de dire que dans ce secteur
dans cette ellipse insulaires à telle ou
telle heure ou à tel ou tel moment il y
a une densité important par exemple
samedi après midi lorsque les gens
fréquentent les commerces et cela
suffirait largement mais vous avez
d'autres quartiers à strasbourg qui ne
sont absolument pas concernés par des
grandes ou forte densité de population
ni le jour et encore moins bien entendu
la nuit vous clients ils dénoncent aussi
une atteinte à la liberté fondamentale
avec cette décision du conseil d'état
oui tout à fait et c'est ce qu'a dit
d'ailleurs le tribunal mistra team de
strasbourg uds c'est ce qui a été
confirmé par le conseil d'état puisque
de liberté sont ici enfreinte d'une part
la liberté d'aller et de venir et
d'autre part le respect des libertés
individuelles c'est à dire le respect de
la vie privée lorsque le fait de devoir
porter en permanence à l'extérieur un
masque enfreint la liberté individuelle
puisque ce n'est pas la même chose se
vêtir avec un masque ou sans masque
c'est clairement une cela enfreint
clairement le respect au droit à la vie
privée
c'est ce qui a été dit à deux reprises
est-ce qu'il faut privilégier la liberté
à à la sentais réellement alors les deux
ne font pas contradictoire et c'est
précisément ce qui avait été demandé par
la loi des confirmands d'une part et par
le décret du mois de juillet d'autre
part c'est à dire que lui préférons le
droit de prendre des mesures
restrictives de liberté individuelle
pour des raisons sanitaires liés aux
qu'ovide mais à la condition de
caractériser les raisons pour lesquelles
ils prennent ces mesures c'est à dire
d'une part de ne pas prendre des mesures
d'ordre général et globale donc il
mesure limitée et de dire pour quelles
raisons elles sont prises et pour
combien de temps or ce à quoi on assiste
est ici de la part de la préfet du
bas-rhin ce sont des mesures à caractère
général et absolu et c'est ce qui a été
condamné par le tribunal mixte ratifiée
par le conseil d'état il faut limiter en
secteur jérôme confié aux graphiques et
de préférence en or à ermont la question
de l'horaire n'a finalement pas été
confirmée par le conseil d'état mais
c'est la philosophie de la chose et
quels sont les recours à votre niveau
maintenant
alors pour l'instant il n'y a plus de
recours contre la décision du conseil
d'état puisque nous étions en dernière
instance
en revanche nous avons appris il y a
environ une heure que madame le préfet
du bas rhin a pris un nouvel arrêté
respectivement a pris cette fois 13
arrêté pour les 13 communes du bas rhin
un cours strasbourg et donc douze autres
pour les 12 autres communes et nous
avons été malheureusement
désagréablement surpris de constater que
la préfète du bas rhin ne respecte pas
la décision du conseil d'état
la méprise même totalement puisque sur
strasbourg elle a décidé de reconduire
purement et simplement son arrêté
précédent c'est-à-dire d'imposer jour et
nuit le port du masque à l'extérieur sur
l'ensemble de la commune de strasbourg
où vous allez quel recours
nous allons en discuter avec eux nos
clients et nous verrons si nous
formerons un nouveau recours tout
simplement merci beaucoup à vous m marc
gens pour vyas que d'avoir été en direct
avec nous le rappelle vous êtes avant
tout merci